[Music]
as welcome to session 43 of worlds
speculative fiction this time we're
looking at and I'm sure I'm gonna screw
up his name a little bit I even had to
look up how to pronounce it and so maybe
one of you can correct me if you know
China me advil is a Zen sound write me a
bill you know I think I saw something
like that so we're looking at the boss
log novels two of which I have here at
Purdue drill Street Station and the scar
and then there's the iron counsel as
well and so you know well they both know
how we how we do this we've got some
biography I came up with some
interesting passages that tie in with
philosophical themes and world building
for China me Havel and I managed to find
a man a decent man that was printable of
the boss log universe or at least the
two continents and the ocean that that
are the main bit of it sometimes you
know when I when I first thought of this
series and called it worlds of
speculative fiction I thought well you
know world building is always really
central and some of the people that
we've looked at didn't do an awful lot
of world building at all and with this
it's almost the the opposite it's not
Tolkien level where he's actually
written out grammars of languages or
anything like that but this is pretty
lush world building that's that's going
on with many different interesting races
and geography and a whole back history
and so there's you know I think we have
a lot to talk about with that and
there's you know sometimes we have to
struggle a little bit with with finding
philosophical themes but again we have
an embarrassment of riches with with
this because he's got philosophers in
the thing and all sorts of philosophical
disquisitions and dialogues going on but
there's so there's also some some big
grand themes that I think are flowing
through it like the nature of politics
and what cities are like one of the
things I actually wanted to talk about
because he's staked out of position on
this is post-modernism because he gets
called a postmodern author but he
explicitly rejects that that title for
certain reasons that have to do with
what post-modernism turned into largely
in the the British scene and it's
interesting I didn't realize that he he
and I went to college at the same time
and he's two years younger than I am so
you know a lot of the things that he did
at certain times I can think about what
was going on in the culture around that
that time and and some of it you know I
think you could see flowing into it so
look should we start with a biography
and you know it's fairly short because
he hasn't lived that long and he hasn't
died so thanks what's that yeah exactly
they seem he seems like he's pretty
healthy you know he's fit and I think he
eats right and all that sort of stuff so
he's born in in Norwich and his parents
he said a couple different interviews
were hippies so they they're playing
around with a book and that's how he got
the name China because they thought it
just seemed like a cool thing his middle
name is Tom so I'm sure he probably yeah
absolutely if you want if you'd liked
him that's sure yeah that sounds good
thanks and and his parents separated
soon after that his father really
doesn't play much of a role in his life
but his mother moves them to London and
he he goes first - you know what would
be our public schools and then begins
attending private schools scholarships
when he's about 11 or so and then pretty
early on you know his parents really
were hippie types and he always had sort
of a leftist perspective and when he was
quite young 13 he begins
engaging in this in serious ways with
political campaigns and marches and
demonstrations you think about what the
80s was like I mean it's it's one thing
for people to be politically engaged say
on Twitter or Facebook where there's
almost no cost right people can can
portray themselves as being a activist
Instagram another another great example
- but or I suppose YouTube alright you
can you can make a youtube video and be
like down with this and we should do
this and there there's whole universes
out there but you actually at some point
in time actually have to get out into
the street and sign things and present
your not just your image but your actual
body in places in order to to do things
and so the eighties you know there was
quite a lot of that going on eventually
his mother is going to move out of
London and at that time he begins
attending a boarding school which he
said was was pretty terrible but you
know allowed him to continue his
education to me he graduates in 1990 and
then does a gap year teaching English
for a year in Egypt and travelling to
some Jim Bob way and around that time he
starts mapping out the the world that's
going to
figure into these these novels the boss
live universe he then goes to study at
Clare College Cambridge and originally
he starts doing English which you know
good choice for a writer right and he
says that he couldn't really stand it
because of the way that things are being
taught at the time so he goes into
social anthropology instead and you know
it's kind of I'll mention something that
that happened to me when I was in
college in a much different situation
you know a little rural school rather
than being in the heart of London or
anything like that or or in this case
Cambridge I I would go to these writing
classes because a lot of my friends were
in English and I was doing philosophy at
math Americas and there is a professor
there who we all kind of idolized he was
one of these you know didn't care about
anything had tenure I would tell people
that their poetry was no good and then
every once in a while surprised them by
saying that this this part here is you
know you might be able to do something
with it
and I I was I didn't have I wasn't
dependent on him for a praise or because
I wasn't one of the English majors and
everybody else sort of hung on on his
words and I went to him one day in his
office and I said listen I really want
to be a writer and I think I'm thinking
about changing my major from philosophy
and the philosophy department there was
not very good at all I'm gonna change
from philosophy to English what do you
think about that oh that's a terrible
idea
and I said why all these people who are
in the writing program you know all
they're learning is is writing and you
know they're they're reading this
certain Canon of stuff you're reading
other stuff that'll actually probably
pay off for you more as a writer you
know you should actually I don't care if
it's philosophy or history or sociology
Jesus don't study writing study that
thing and then write on the side and
it'll turn out
- so you got that advice yep interests
then you did the PPE program right yeah
and actually I have super misses people
who come out of yeah yeah you know I
think you can also you can generalize
that about other professional degrees as
well because the MFA is a essentially a
professional degree it's a finishing
degree you know there are some things
you learn doing an NDA reading certain
statements you know certain types of
marketing there's a lot of jargon that
you learn but that doesn't necessarily
make a person better at a lot of the
operational stuff for business and there
there are some people who don't want to
hire MBAs for that reason and they hire
liberal arts majors instead a lot of it
has to do with like effectiveness of
communication and problem-solving and so
any in any case he studies some social
anthropology and he's a sort of a fast
track he gets done pretty early
graduates from from Cambridge in three
years begins working as a an editor on a
computer magazine and he starts working
on his master's degree in international
law this was the one in School of
Economics at the same time the 1995 his
father dies and he also receives his
master's degree and then begins working
on his PhD in there I don't have it in
here but he actually did a fellowship at
Harvard for for about a year as well and
he publishes his first major novel King
rat in 1998 Perdido straight steeds
Street Station is going to follow not
that long after that and in 2001 he gets
his PhD in international law which he'll
publish later on
as between equal rights of Marxist
theory of international law nonfiction
work he's got a few non-fiction works in
there and that same year he does a
couple other things he gets the arthur c
clarke award and british fantasy award
for Perdita's street station so this
really establishes his reputation and
he's also a candidate for the House of
Commons for the Socialist Alliance I
think that in his seat if I remember
right he gets about three percent of the
vote which for a you know minority party
is actually not that bad he's got to go
around canvassing you know doing all the
sorts of things that you do then he
follows that up with the scar and the
pain in 2002 the scar wins awards as
well and so you know the series is off
to a good start and in it's it's
interesting to when you when you think
about the series these are set in the
same universe and I don't have I don't
have the iron counsel but it's Satan
universe as well and there's all these
reference points that are together but
it's sort of like the when we talked
about Ian banks culture series you know
there's a common universe and there's
some back and forth of reference points
but the characters don't meet it really
you know interact or anything like that
they're they're stories within a shared
narrative space as time goes on he
writes quite a few other works on London
sort of play on words on London then he
writes Red Planet's Marxism and science
fiction which is another nonfiction work
and that same year that's okay
in 2009 he writes the city in the city
which which has been adapted well I have
one adaptation of it that got adapted in
2013 at the lifeline Theatre in Chicago
so that's kind of you know interesting
and there's there's talk about doing
like film or TV adaptations but as it
often works with these things those take
a long time and it seems difficult to
actually pull them off but he he goes on
and he is at you know writing
professionally doing more and more and
more and then eventually you know starts
starts getting more involved in in the
political scene than he already was he
resigns from the Socialist Workers Party
in 2013 over a scandal that that took
place about rape allegations and then he
joined with some other people including
other you know creative types but but
other other politicals as well in
forming this the left unity which
doesn't seem to go on too far but you
know Britain is kind of a tough place to
to pull that sort of thing off the left
seems right now pretty disorganized and
you know and you you've gave quite a few
interviews in in recent times about what
was going on and practices and things
like that so he's written quite a few
things recently as well not none of
which have to do with the boss log
universe this census taker days last
days of new Paris another nonfiction
work October the story of the revolution
revolution and this year he you know
he's got another one a Spectre haunting
Europe so I believe so yeah and and I
think you know he is a yeah I guess you
can say he's a Marxist he's not
necessarily like an orthodox Marxist
you know the putting capital and
everybody's face sort of thing there's
but there's a great deal more
flexibility and the Marxist movement
over there and you know that's a famous
reference of course Marx's Communist
Manifesto Spectre is haunting Europe
that of communism and so actually that
that's sort of a good launching point
into the thing about post-modernism so
let's talk about that and then we'll
come to the nearer to the universe right
away cuz it'll be a nice segue to so
this is from an interview of 2003 he
says I don't really accept the term
postmodern as explaining very much in
the real world I'd use it as a
description for certain schools of
theory in certain schools of art I don't
consider myself a post modernist in any
real sense so already there he's he's
doing something that I myself respect
quite a bit which is to not use this
term postmodern and a sort of sloppy it
covers everything kind of loosey-goosey
sense that a lot of people do
either positively because they say oh we
all have to be postmoderns or pomo you
know or negatively the way that we've
seen in the last 10 years or people are
not in the past people would complain
about you know relativism or secular
humanism and now they they say they just
say post-modernism as if that's like
this Bugaboo that covers everything and
there is you know there is movements
that are postmodern in art and in
literature and in philosophy but that's
sort of high theory stuff you know
that's that's not just somebody getting
on on YouTube and and you know talking
about memes or something like that and
there being some self reference then
that's not enough to actually make it
postmodern that's very modern actually
and he so he thinks that it doesn't
explain very much and then he's the here
he's changing it a little bit to talk
about the people who are post modernists
he says post-modernism has done a quite
a good job of colonizing lots of
techniques and implying that anything
those techniques is therefore
postmodernist so you know if there's an
unreliable there right it's postmodern
but unreliable narrators have been
around for quite a while and it you know
you could easily harness it for well
here's here's a great example you know
if you want to call you know Louis
Farrakhan Celine's journey to the end of
night a post modernist novel because
there's you know some skipping around
and and a pretty unreliable narrator and
some kind of sir realistic stuff going
on that really glosses over how how not
conservative but and not even
traditional but sort of like nihilistic
the the novel is but nihilistic in a
conservative way and you know that's
that's early twentieth century
literature right so just because
something has a few traits of what we
consider postmodern doesn't make it
postmodern but I think a lot of people
glommed on to that and I remember that
you know in the 90s that was sort of
like the big thing everything needed to
be postmodern and nobody could tell you
what it meant so he says you can see
certain deconstructive techniques for
example without being a post modernist
still being here he lays his hand out
being a classical Marxist so he says I
realize that this is a bit of a semantic
quibble if someone finds it useful to
describe my stuff in that way that's up
to them but I'd resist it because I
don't think it's fair that hybridity
uncertainty blurring identities
fracturing formal experimentation or the
blurring of high and low culture should
be ceded to post-modernism that's that's
an interesting thing to say he says I
want all that and I'm a classical
Marxist you might say well what's what's
the problem you know cuz because
nowadays we have all these people are
like you know blurring cultural Marxism
and post-modernism and you know they're
they're equated the two and and then you
know people point out well think all
these are actually quite quite different
Marxist believe that there is
something that postmodernists typically
reject there's a grand narrative and in
the grand narrative there are some some
you know features to it that that run
throughout like you know mark says that
history is a history of class struggles
you don't have to buy into that a
hundred percent say it's only a history
of class struggles but if you if you say
that class struggle doesn't play a role
you're probably not a Marxist at that
point right no I know how you package
yourself and so the post modernists you
know quite often like he says the
postmodern term was used too often as a
stick tip with which to beat Marxism
that meant that when I became a Marxist
there was a certain polemical importance
to pointing out that many of the
critical tools associated with
post-modernism could also be used by
those of us Cheerilee hanging on to
meta-narratives you know stories about
what what's what's actually going on you
know like the working class has been
progressively you know screwed over in a
lot of ways in the last say 30 years
wages of state stagnant the cost of
living has gone up in all these
different ways that could be a Marxist
narrative right and a post modernist
would have to say oh well you know we're
we to judge maybe maybe you shouldn't
have this so much certainty about that
and Marx this would say no there you
know we could be wrong about this but
you know we're gonna we're gonna take
our stand on this so he says let me skip
down a little bit it's the big claims of
post-modernism and to be fair generally
when I consider the vulgar end of
postmodern light bouldery art and his
epigraph that I wanted to dissociate
myself from and then he says he was
particularly sharp in social
anthropology where the cultural
relativism led to some terrible
capitulations to inequity
I reject post modernity as a description
of the world we live I would argue in
late capitalism in the post label and
nothing particularly useful so that's a
that's a you know very clear statement I
think
you know he's telling us where he stands
there's other there's other theorists
who kind of fit into that somebody that
I remember you know saying a lot of
those sort of things back in the 90s was
Terry Eagleton who was a Marxist
esthetician you know and he would he
would look at these these texts that
everyone was saying well you know we
can't really figure out what they're
about and say no no we can we can say
these things are about this and we can
say that these cultural per unit
processes lead to this and this this is
actually problematic and we should
probably try to change this in the
publishing industry there were some
other you know good books along those
lines
Samuel Harrington had that the politics
at God's funeral where he was worrying
about that and I think that came out
saying late 80s or early 90s and so
memo's is kind of locating himself
within a particular tradition
one important expositor of
post-modernism when people's you know
asked me this they talked about the
postmodern I said wow it's more
complicated than you think they always
said well who should I read them and I
usually say well I mean you could read
leotard who coined the phrase in the
postmodern condition or you could read
Frederick Jameson's massive book
post-modernism the cultural logic of
late capitalism and one of the things
that I think is I was thinking about
this on the drive over so one way that
that Jameson talks about post-modernism
after surveying what what other people
mean by it he says that you can think of
it as a recognition that nobody really
knows what's going on and so the the
distrust of master or meta-narratives
wouldn't just be like well you can't
ever tell a story man because the story
is always going to be false in some way
alright it's not this this sort of
knee-jerk response
it's rather a recognition that every
every way in which we reframe things
doesn't just already contain some
contradictions
you know blind spots that we needed to
fill in its that we don't really we
don't really know there's like I was a
sort of a shadow a penumbra at the
outside we don't really know what's
determining what we know what we see we
know that there are systems complicated
systems that we can wrap our heads
around we don't know how far those
actually extend or how true they are and
yet we still have to make choices and
operate within them that's what Jameson
talks about and man does that look like
the world in these books right nobody
truly knows exactly what's going on
because everything is in some respect to
vast for any one single mind to take it
all in but everybody's got some sort of
scheme and some local understanding of
their portion of the world that could be
wrong and could be investigated further
but you know that end will change the
world as well by what they do but nobody
truly knows what's going on probably
including bless you me a bill and so I
was thinking on the way over so here
you'd be something to kick kick off some
discussion we normally think of an
author as essentially like the God
overseeing their creation right and we
can have different sorts like you know
the difference between Tolkien as the
architect and george RR martin as the
gardener who plants seeds and then just
sees how things develop it's still it's
still george RR martin using his brain
space for these characters to grow right
so we shouldn't like pretend that
somehow he just plot you know plotted a
bunch of things in holes somewhere and
watered them and they
grew up and then he like documented it
no it's it's it's within his writing
process so me Ethel knows this world
right in in these books very thick books
because he's the one who came up with
that but he's able to portray to us a
world that not only for the characters
but also for us as the readers always
remains you know all sorts of complex
systems that that do remain outside of
our grass where some of the earth and
he's good at portraying characters
knowing things that they talk about and
then don't talk about further so I'll
put it I'll put the question this way is
is he in some respect to postmodern
author in that he doesn't actually know
what what's going on with his own
creation or is he is is there some sort
of sleight of hand going on in it
narrative Lee what do what do you think
this is speculative because there's some
point I think he describes it the ball
takes place on a flat plane and it's
basically impossible to find a limit to
it which gave me the sense that as an
author at the very least he was leaving
himself an out to develop and discover
some of why you can't get the can't go
certain places no like so north of new
chromosome yeah is the grand grist and
you know then that plays a major part in
the scar that's where the grind a little
bit and and they're these weird
creatures that are incredibly dangerous
you could say capricious but we don't
even know enough about them to say
whether they're capricious or that they
will trade with human beings on weird
terms and give them good things and then
if you transgress any of their rules
none of which the human beings actually
know they will essentially just eat you
and their their horrific and strong
track you for thousands of miles across
the ocean so that you know that closes
off the North right it's sort of like
it'd be like if you had a video game you
just have like bosses on bosses on
bosses that can't be beaten
at that point well that that's no longer
explorable alright so I think that's
part of it but what about what about
like the the structure of like you know
the city or Armada in this but you've
got this vast this vast place where the
story takes place with all these
interlocking systems can anybody
understand all how all they they fit
together like to do you think yeah bill
doesn't understand tokens world isn't in
some respect a little simpler isn't it
yeah it even feels a little under
populated interesting well it is sort of
class wise evil has more characters and
he has more typos types of characters
Tolkien is still mostly
the nobility or the gentry their respect
it sort of like in fashion history right
yeah yeah you get a lot of what they
what they called in the early in the
late 19th century and early 20th century
the demi-monde the people who were
typically anywhere from like lower-class
all the way up to you know sometimes
upper middle class but rarely that
usually like lower middle class or
perhaps making it into middle class and
they they serve the people who were the
elite whether they were the the moneyed
or the writ or you know the powerful or
the old families or something like that
so you know think about people who would
be like professional caterers or
courtesans or musicians they never
really had that much social capital but
they dress for those those places and
those people you know I think there's a
lot of characters like that in here but
you act academics you know like Isaac
there's a whole you know university
scene going on which is kind of
interesting
universities are always kind of a weird
mixie place when it comes to class
aren't they there's think about it this
way like if you have a traditional
factory town right well you know who the
rich people are they are the factories
and then there's the people who do all
the services for them that are important
enough to pay a lot for like their
accountants and lawyers and doctors and
you know this and that and then there's
you know another strata below them and
then there's the strata of people who do
the majority of the work and then
there's a lower strata yet of people who
do other work and you look down upon
even the workers so that's pretty pretty
you know straightforward and in an
academic area you still have some of
that but a lot of things are kind of
upset you have people coming in who be
by virtue of the fact that education can
sometimes like raise you out of here
your social class into a different
social class can can move up or let
people fall down you know it's not you
know what does a chair of it's perfect
they're a boss but what sort of you know
social status do they have in town it's
probably fairly low unless it's a
prestigious department you know so
there's that and then there's all this
other stuff going on as well within the
city and that's just a city you know so
well what else should we say about this
world that he's built I mean its vast it
encompasses like you're saying it's if
Tolkien is underpopulated this is
teeming with what is the positive
medieval view series where you get like
yeah so we've heard that this weird
stuff is out there your average medieval
person is not going to run into them but
like a unicorn
yes but they firmly believe they are out
there because people have that leg is
kind of like that over there and there
is the sense that your local person on
the ground
is aware that there are monsters out
there and might or might not ever meet
them and is never going to fully
understand them but that's just how it
is
yeah even though that's not a medieval
world when I was researching this one of
the things that came across it was kind
of interesting was whether just talking
about the grinding low again and so
there are these races that are clearly
non-human but are well incorporated
within human society like the cactus
people and the Caffery and I forget the
name of the toad that's the Frog like
creatures and voles some vole Donny is
it so they're you know they're more or
less well understood and and people
might have prejudice against them or
exploit them but they know where they
they fit in and they know that they're
you know more or less gonna act
similarly to human beings and then
there's the grindy low and one of the
one of the things that came across said
it's not quite sure whether they should
they should classify them as monsters or
or essentially a race that's that's sort
of like humans because their psychology
is different enough that it's tough to
to fit them in whereas like the vampires
and the there's an OP dead not undead
the OP dead in high chroma Lac okay
there they're clearly you know within
the realm you we might actually say are
they within the realm of not rational
beings but human-like beings human-like
enough beings you know I mean
traditionally we've I think about the
manual cut for example if we run into
aliens either they're they're rational
like us human beings even if they've got
in a weird floppy things all over the
place and eight eyes and you know I
don't eat cubes of
this is gelatin or something like that
they still have to treat them as persons
because they have the same basic
structure of agency they they probably
have a different psychology than we do
but we can strip that away or we can say
that there's something distinctively
rational and therefore person like I
don't know that that works that well for
this you know where would we draw the
line between monster and human-like
being
clearly the Avant in the scar that
massive creature that they have
underneath you know trying to use it as
a yeah it's providing this providing the
the harnessed essentially right that
doesn't count as a a human and that's
that's one reason why they can you know
use it as a beast of burden but these
others how do they you know how do they
fit in and there's not a lot to talk
about that there's a lot of people just
sort of act as if well there's these
frog like creatures I guess we got to
deal with them Council where it's almost
like this passing line um there's a mind
because it's sort of an industrial
revolution style world and they're
reminding the marrow out of the bones of
a dead god they just toss this aside
like it's nothing yeah and like they
have the massive creatures like whatever
it's just like there's something so vast
potent and now it's dead and now they're
just using it for raw materials yeah
well I mean that's a theme that runs
through a lot of this stuff right what
would we call it like repurposing of the
great sort of comes back to a Marxist I
think you can't get much more material
history than turning a dead God into
materials and commodities yeah well I
was also thinking about the big ship
that was like you know it was a really
big thing for again new chromosome and
sort of like their Titanic I guess in a
way and it gets lost and it gets
incorporated into Armada as part of the
structure of it right furnishing raw
materials and so yeah yeah materialism
you know it's in this is another good
thing that's kind of interesting to
think about so Aristotle you know brings
in this whole discussion of teleology
that's quite complex and interesting but
Aristotle is biased towards a thing
really has its purpose and anything else
you know you can do other stuff with it
but it's not really for that and he
criticizes in the politics he criticizes
this forget the name of the knife and it
wasn't sort of like a Swiss Army knife
it was a multi-purpose tool and he says
that it's not it's not very good because
you know obviously you do better when
you stick to one one purpose and you
know you you read that you're like he's
a pretty smart guy but that doesn't
really make sense because there are some
things that really only work for one
purpose but so many other things can be
easily repurposed in so many other ways
and it's like we we introduce as human
beings we
introduce new teleology into the things
that we work with and that is a point
that that you know the Marxists among
others make that this repurposing or
mission creep or however we want to
frame it is something that's kind of
endemic to us as creatures and the other
races too are doing that as well they're
adapting to new circumstances you know
like the Caffrey who come into new
chromosome don't have to build a new
life for themself
I mean they're actually they're they're
they're mad master repurpose ORS making
their art out of chewing stuff up and
spitting it into shape right and that it
becomes something that can be sold to
the to the people the humans to make a
buck there were there was some other oh
yeah they're going going back to the
world-building thing there were two
things I wanted to talk about in here
one was the Tolkien thing so he actually
wrote a piece called there and back
again five reasons Tolkien rocks sort of
a response to people who are like you
know Tolkien as a fascist and you know
his stuff is no good we got to get
totally away from that and he he listed
things like you know you incorporating
Norse mythology the the creature in the
water was another one of the great
reasons he talked to how good Tolkien
was that had like making monsters and he
says the author of the century needs no
help from anyone least of all spec like
me no force on earth could undermine the
juggernaut in play implacability of his
sales or the world historical scale of
his influence nor the truly enormous
weight of his achievement he puts the
word epic and epic win however or more
accurately because of that every few
years certain has tied someone will
write a splenetic screed against the
professor explaining why he's the devil
the worst things to happen to fantasy
the voice of reaction oh my god the most
boring writer ever etc he says the
oedipal resentment motivating many of
these attacks may be trivially obvious
especially from those from within
fantastic fiction but it doesn't follow
the substance of all the criticism is
baseless there's perfectly reasonable
arguments to be had about the impact
nature scale and successive tokens work
the sheer religious zealotry with which
some Tolkien ace does defend the master
when it ignores those grounds for debate
and refuses to countenance a flaw
anywhere within the middle-earth II and
edifice doesn't then help matters even
more nuance Pro Hobbit partisans
sometimes choose to look to - some of us
to be questionable grounds for defense
because there are arguments not only
about what is regrettable and Tolkien
but what is indispensable accordingly
what follows and he gives a list and of
some perhaps in some cases somewhat
insufficiently stressed reasons why we
all should be terribly grateful to to
Tolkien so you know it's kind of an
interesting ground to stake out but I
think that you know the interesting
thing is when you're like a bonafide
attach to some sort of tradition and the
Marxism is essentially a tradition at
this point I like a MacIntyre in
tradition and MacIntyre himself was a
Marxist I think that's what part of
where we're
of his impetus has always come from it
allows you a certain freedom to reach
across lines and take on things that
people who are maybe a little less
secure in their ideological commitments
can't do you know why do people have to
attack pelicans so so much and you know
say well we have to get beat get get get
beyond him why why not appropriate the
things that are good and then also say
you know if you if you think about you
know I like reading Cora answers and
questions about various things the Lord
of the Rings is one of them and people
will ask things about how that universe
could actually function you know what is
it like for these these these works for
example it turns out it and that's
hulking himself had some some real
worries about that because works
actually tokens of you know good
Catholic orcs have souls
yeah corrupted Souls but it seems like
they're really in a screwed position by
virtue of being the kind of things that
they are and if Tolkien himself is
worried about these sorts of things I
think it seems you know perfectly fine
to worry about that but we can recognize
what's you know what Tolkien did for you
know creating the possibility for epic
fiction that I think can lead to this
isn't quite epic fiction he describes it
as new weird the other thing that I
thought was kind of interesting that I
had put a this is a coming from another
interview he says that one of the most
enduring influences on him was dungeons
and dragons and other role-playing games
playing it as a kid and so in 2003 says
I've not played for 16 years and have
absolutely no intention of starting
again but so this goes right to the
point about the bestiary z-- I still buy
and read the manuals occasionally there
were two things about them that
particularly influenced me one was the
mania for cataloging the fantastic if
you play them for any length of time you
you know pretty much all the
mythological beasts of all the
Pantheon's out there along with a fair
bit of the theology I still love that I
collect fantastic beastie Ares and one
of the main Spurs to write a secondary
world fantasy again that's a Tolkien
sort of term right was to invent a bunch
of monsters half of which all I'm sure
I'll never be able to fit into any books
so that's that's you know an interesting
point and then he goes on and he says
the other more nebulous but very strong
influence of RPGs was the weird fetish
for systemization the way everything is
reduced to game stance if you take
something like a thule and love craft
for example it's completely
incomprehensible and beyond human
categorization but in the game call a
catullo you see Cthulhu's strength
dexterity and so on
carefully expects expressed numerically
there's something banal fiying about
that approach to the fantastic on one
level of misses the point entirely
but I must admit it appeals to me and
it's a application of some weirdly
misplaced rigor to the fantastic I think
that's part of what's going on in this
there's there is a rigor to and
systematize ation but we don't actually
get to see the system we only get we
only know that a system is there and
people are referencing it and bringing
up books of hypotheses and you know all
of that sort of stuff and and so for me
until he says he got that you know in
part by the influence of role-playing
games which i think is kind of kind of
funny I also remember there's a total
trivia because I used to play D&D way
back in the day when I was a kid and I
think they had to take this out of later
editions because they got sued over it
but in the early in the early like
advanced D&D game the Cthulhu Mythos was
was part of it and they had stands for
all these things and then somebody sued
them I think and they took it out but it
wouldn't it wouldn't really have fit
that well into the D&D universe anyway
what if that was all kind of arranged
right all of all the different evil
beings had their different planes and
all the good beings did but Cthulhu you
know and you know all the other mythos
beings I don't know if we can call them
gods the old ones they they they mess up
everything you bring them in and it's
it's it's a mess you know so that's you
know I think that gives you a little bit
of interesting background as to what's
going on in these these works obviously
it's much much less about fighting and
more about spying and and figuring out
how to do research and remake people and
make a balk and stuff like that then the
role-playing games tend to be you know
and personal relationships too there was
you know there was another theme I
wanted to bring up as well and we've
already touched down in a bit
and I'm not going to read the whole
passage as I have with these others but
you got you got a lot of flack for how
political iron Counsel was viewed as
being and it seems you know reading the
other books they're intensely political
there's there's all this political
back-and-forth going on not just in in
new chromazone imperative parody doe
Street Station itself right and then
descriptions about how things are
working but this book is about a
floating
city that has its own constituencies in
these these different sectors of the
city made of old ships and they have to
work out what they're going to do as a
hybrid people whether they're gonna you
know raise and chain the evanka and go
all the way to the scar or abandon this
project and there's there's a lot of
back-and-forth political machination I
think when people complain about novels
or films or stuff like that being
political I think a lot of the time it's
because it's it's that it's it's it's an
it's not necessarily endorsing but it's
narrating a politics that they don't
like you know iron Council you could say
is is more socialist or more Marxist in
that respect but a good Marxist is
always trying to see how you know
societies arranged and now the
institution's function and that's just a
materialist approach to things seems
like an iron Council it gets viewed as
political because he's portraying things
oh just like when people get upset about
you know I don't know bringing female
characters in to popular franchises and
actually giving them command positions
or more you know air time or agency or
more backstory there's always somebody
who's like oh why do you have to
politicize everything and in a way it's
I mean it is politicizing it because you
know we all know that banal saying
everything is political right but it's
not it's not it's not politicizing it as
opposed to other ways of telling the
story you know just having a bunch of
dudes running around shooting everything
in sight that's political too you know
so he did say that that the the some
people were saying this is me ovals
breakthrough book he's moved to a
different level
and he said the critical reception at
the pro level has been quite good the
critical reception at the fan level has
been quite troubled and though that's
kind of an interesting take at it and
they keep saying this in 2005 just a
year after the book has been published
so I was going to see what it what do
you make of that is it is it a more he
says this is the most overtly political
book I've ever written it's a book that
features a lot of sexual politics which
some people won't necessarily like but
there's a lot of sexual politics and
both of these to 2004 yeah I mean if
it's interesting how and the space of 25
years or so the the holes are like
marriage equality and gay liberation and
representation movement essentially
succeeded in most places you know if you
think I guess yeah in the early 2000s it
was still such a hotly contested issue
whereas now that one's that one's you
know more or less behind us so if we can
have a gay candidate for president
who interestingly a lot of a lot of gay
people and other people in the LGBTQ
whole thing are not supporting cuz thank
you for various reasons I mean that's
actually a sign that you've made it
right when you're not gonna be endorsed
by your group it and yeah I mean you
still do have a lot of people like
railing against the gay agenda or
homosexuality is as sinful and stuff
like that but but a bit iffy but if you
do it in a TV show or a movie or things
like that like let's say we've made
Ironman gay you know
yeah I think a lot of Marvel fans would
be quite upset at that or bisexual or or
whatever it's funny I mean you can put
there's like so many different like
unwritten rules about where you where
you could push an envelope as a writer
and where you couldn't you know I guess
I suppose a lot of it depends on fan
base doesn't
oh right yeah yeah being sort of the
wrong kind of immigrant it's fiction but
it's fiction so and yeah like a lot of
it doesn't do anything with her
nationality because there are Mexican
and Latino writers who could have yeah I
mean that comes up a lot in film and
television - right where you know you
should there's gonna be a character
who's you know say East Asian and then
they they still pick you know big
Hollywood actress or actor to play them
and give them some makeup things like
that wonder why I mean you could say
that there that that's probably
something that still is an issue across
the board no matter what we want to pick
sometimes I will say this and I always
see everything I think both ways
the devil's advocate speaking back to
counseling yeah the biggest mom always
in the counseling room was well if
you're recovering addict you can work
with the you know alcoholic drug knows
clients if you're this you know and I
always say well you know sorry to break
it to you but I'm not gonna go home and
tell me how it's gonna beat the crap out
of me so I can always yeah yeah yeah
yeah you recognize I can have empathy
you know and I gonna do agree with doing
your homework or trail people who sort
of have pushed like to make sure you say
you're telling the experience authentic
lis I want to know your history yeah
it's sort of like a client credential
yes like you know that's actually really
messed up for you to say you don't have
the right to say you know I I always
thought that this you can't understand a
particular point of view unless you you
have some unless you're either coming
from it or you've got some like
irrefutable connection to it like I
didn't you know I'm not this but I have
a child who's this or I'm married to
this yeah well I was led that from a
philosophical perspective you know it
didn't make sense because if we actually
followed out that logic then nobody
would actually be able to relate to
anybody you know
we could always like split things down
further and further and further and
further and so clearly that doesn't work
and then the more the more interesting
thing is in trying to refute it and say
ah see I've proven that your you know
your your thing is wrong but to say well
how would we make inroads then how do we
tell between you know a you know fairly
reliable or faithful portrayal of this
particular group or issue or something
like that we should yeah that's
something that some of my students have
brought up in classes you know that they
don't like being made into the token
acts then that it's I mean it's it's
unfair for them to have to work harder
than everybody else anyway because of
that but they also don't like getting
pigeon holed into being you know yeah
well people go as far as to say to my
son it's black because you wait mom
you're not oh yeah that's opinions out
there as to what things are yeah should
ask them if they think the same about
Obama well
come on but again people have yeah I
think you know the family is like oh
yeah one of the things then we're
getting kind of far away from yeah but
there's something I've been thinking
about a lot lately because we're now in
this this much more connected world you
know internet infused world where where
the the tempo of everything is sped up
very very quickly if you like say
something on Twitter people know about
it on the other side of the world if
they're following you within within
minutes it's I think there's there's a
tendency for anything that we say to
draw contradiction and criticism very
quickly and it can it can replicate
itself whereas in the past if I was like
I don't know I let's say I'm portraying
myself as like an expert on Billy Budd
right you know and I talked about it all
the time and people would be like well
it's kind of a weird trait of his but
you know he's the Billy Budd guy right
and and let's say somebody else's was
there and they're like I don't think he
actually knows much about this and they
they say they say it but nobody else is
actually paying attention to them throw
that shut up you know the professors to
talk things just something like that
he's he's been in the Navy he he knows
about this sort of thing that's somebody
else he's never actually had to like you
know execute somebody well I'm sure he
can put himself in their shoes you know
you knew somebody who executed somebody
you know some some nonsense like that so
in the past so you could still get
dragged down pretty pretty quickly and
it happened to lots of people and lots
of different ways often quite unfairly
but now really any position that you
take you can encounter opposition to it
and very often
poorly thought-out just sort of almost
like picking up on only one-tenth of
what you're saying kind of opposition
very quickly and and I think that's the
normal condition now and it's you know
for those of us who are older and maybe
know how to push back and not take it to
heart too easily it's it's just an
annoyance
you know waste waste some of our time
arguing with people who you know you see
you think they're arguing a good faith
but they're not or something like that
but I think for a lot of young people
that are growing up in that matrix and
have really never known anything other
than that it's there's something I think
maybe noxious about it that I worry
about you know on the one hand you know
young people know that they if they post
stuff in social media or they they say
something they could be being filmed on
the strip there's something like that
they know that that stuff can can spread
very quickly but they also don't have
that you know that awareness all the
time and they're you know I think
there's not as much awareness to about
how I everything out there is and then
the ones that are aware of that I'm sure
that must have kind of a dampening
effect on them they have to like be
worried about you know somebody watching
me at this point in time and now not
even like this is a government watching
me or as Apple watching me or Facebook
or so you know one of the big tech
giants but are are all these other
people that I live with some of whom you
know might have something negative to
say about it doesn't even have to be
something that you say or something that
you do it could just be what you're what
you're wearing or how you're walking or
who I see people getting called out on
Twitter just for following somebody else
you know
and you know because they're they belong
to you if you follow this person and
they have these views therefore you must
be endorsing them and you might be
following them just so you can keep tabs
on I actually get Trump's newsletter in
the email every day and take a look at
it because I was saying like what this
guy is selling as you know the new
Republican line of the day yeah yeah but
somebody could look at that and be like
yeah he's a trump supporter because
because of that and so we're in this
pervasive environment of like constant
vulnerability to to criticism and it's
really you know it's weird it's not when
I said that I thought about you know
like Communist China during the Great
Leap Forward and these these meetings
that people would be dragged to where
then they'd be criticized by their
neighbors and their children and they'd
have to like denounce themselves it's
not it's not centralized like that
instead we're just subject to having all
of these potential jerks who want to
weigh anything that we may want to say
there's there's a corresponding you know
side benefit we can get support from
unusual places that we didn't expect
people can be quite nice and boost you
and you could you could have people make
context for you who are like wow this
person is saying something really good
you should take a look at this but there
is that that that negative side of it
that that wasn't present as we were
growing up you know
you know somebody like China who's still
alive
you know like does that sway him and
determining whether or not he wants to
yeah oh yeah that's yeah I mean he's a
he's a public figure he's been out there
so much over the years and he's you know
he's a committed Marxist so you know
where he stands so any anything that he
does where there's some sort of
identifiable Marxist theme or pushing
anything progressive people are always
even thought that stupid Marxist again
you know it was interesting when or
maybe both depending on the day all
right
yeah you know when you're talking about
with Anna Braddock to during that Oh
Veronica Roth yeah yeah you know like
cuz back to talking about the anxiety or
whatever and she said to oh yeah she was
wondering how her next book was gonna be
received with the fan base supported are
they gonna turn from her yeah that's an
interesting yeah if you're successful
isn't a lot there or any sort of
creative type this happens to bands a
lot with musics here right you make
something your heart is in it it's what
you need to create at that time and
somehow it gets traction because people
like this is actually pretty good and
now your your lock and do you here's
that here's an ethical question I think
a lot of fans feel as if creators have a
moral obligation to keep creating within
that that universe or that style but as
an artist you do you have any sort of
obligation I mean your fans have been
the ones who have spread your your works
and image and probably paid your your
paychecks in many ways right so do you
have to keep on doing things that way
and you know like go ahead
two paychecks authors the shape there
and contractor the publisher can only
just publishing books with that
publisher selling rides like fans
already talk it's like oh I was really
looking forward to book five in the
series what happened and I call the
publisher drop the series because it
wasn't selling enough yeah that's yeah
that's interesting and you could get
pressure from you get pressure from the
the publisher and the editor is saying
oh man you know we really love this sort
of experimental stuff that you do but
maybe not in our series you know with
the fan bases is really looking for this
and and I uh you know personally I love
this creative stuff that you're doing
but can you just like keep it over there
as a side project you know yeah yeah I I
personally I don't think that they they
have an obligation to keep going down a
particular path almost they've like
declare that they're going to or you
know I suppose if you say like george RR
martin right there's a good example is
is he off the hook for books six and
seven i don't i don't feel he is I think
he should finish the series out but but
that's because he said he would write so
one maybe once you say that you will
you can't oh people but you know does
this chinam you know they'll have to
write another boss like he could he'd
write you know twenty more sort of doing
what he advanced it with the culture
series but he I don't think he asked
I don't know I don't know anything about
it other than the title so I expect it's
it's it's a nonfiction you know book of
Marxist historiography I imagine but or
maybe it's taking the stock of you know
where Europe currently is I mean if you
think about it which Specter is the
specter communism probably not
maybe it's fascism maybe it's Russia as
a matter of fact he is alright good I'll
get to use this other passage that I
have that I quoted that we probably
should start ramping up he he talks
about this being particularly terrible
days he's and he's talking about
dystopia and he says it's hard to avoid
the sense that these are particularly
terrible days and that dystopia is
bleeding vividly into the coat ideon and
hence presumably into realism if that
was a category which one was interested
at this point however comes an
obligatory warning about the historical
ubiquity of the questionable believed
that things have got worse and of the
sheer arrogance of disparity and grand
iseman of thinking that one lives in the
worst times hot on the heels of that we
need a counter corrective to it no law
no less arrogant assumption that things
will likely be alright out of fear that
thinking otherwise would indeed be
arrogant so he's saying we got to avoid
two different things we can avoid the
constant thing that he's right if you
look at like literature and history
people are always complaining about how
their time is garbage and you know the
good old days you know or that and
Seneca yeah yeah well he also thought
you shouldn't have too many books so I
think I did but there's no there's
always people who are like well somehow
we're gonna make it through you know
that's that's not so you know cultures
that say that don't always make it
through you know and and there's there's
no guarantee that we have to be like you
know the hyper power or anything like
that and what we do decline away from
that into a more multipolar world man
we're gonna have a reckoning to deal
with I think in terms of which is not
just you know geopolitics but economy
and stuff like that so he goes down and
he says that for me facing all of this
stuff one of the things that he says is
that against surrender to the
complacency and historical myopia of
studies state politics of precluding as
a real possibility epochal degeneration
there's not in living memory but a
better time to be a fascist he says I
think these are dreadful sadistic times
getting worse although with abrupt and
salutary counter tendencies and there's
no reason their endpoint might not be
utter catastrophe for me facing that as
urgent as is the deployment of
categories such as decadence and
barbarism as in socialism or barbarism
and so he goes on and he says that the
horizon is now more visible now to many
who had thought themselves insulated if
they thought about it at all and
dystopia for some this is a great line
is utopia for others so you know we when
we say oh they can't possibly mean X
because that would be crazy talk there's
plenty of people out there who that
crazy talk that is the ideal for them
they're like yeah you know and any
anything that we take for granted is
like having
then settled once and for all like you
know the Holocaust happened and we
shouldn't do that again there's plenty
of people who will they actually do
believe believe the Holocaust happened
but there's in faith I think that was a
great thing and it should have gone
further but they'll die it was a
holocaust burger for a while as well as
part of their their strategy and there's
no guarantee for any given human
tendency that it can't go dark and wrong
and bad in some way so he goes on and he
says here we go
we live in a utopia it's just not ours
it's perfectly abundantly true that the
technocratic centrist socially
neoliberal project of the Democrats and
New Labour is in major crisis and that
in the cracks new forms grow I warn that
project not one iota it deserves to die
and then he says what does not follow of
course see Trump is that whatever rises
in the rubble is an improvement
certainly for me a radical systemic
change is the best hope we have from
moving away from this system of sadism
and I hold the alt center's hope for a
return to the status quo ante ruled by
adults in the room to be not only an
indefensible project but are doomed won
so yes a wholly different kind of
project a revolutionary one an upheaval
an overturning of existing social
priorities of dynamics is what we
deserve and the unhesitating demand for
it is by far our best hope so he said
that in 2018 in this strategy for
ruination and I you know I think he does
have his finger on the pulse of
something that's that's quite real I
think a lot of people did vote for Trump
or voted for you know the Tories or you
Kip or things like that or other other
parties and other platforms because
they're like well this stuff is garbage
I you know I don't see it attending to
me let's shake things up but shaking
things up you know the isn't necessarily
going to work for for for good there has
to be some content there some some
something determinate that says here's
what we actually are standing for and
then that opens you up to criticism you
know how are you gonna pay for that
that's the big one here right if you do
that isn't that marginalizing you're
going to undo the marginalization of
these people well you're just
marginalizing these people over here you
know that's that's another common trope
as well I guess you know that is a good
thing to end on you know in these that
iron iron council is different in that
respect right there isn't any like we're
all in it together I guess there is
there's a bit of that in the scar right
here with the the people of our motto
but they they have to sort their with
their stuff out and Bella sleeves she
doesn't identify with her Mata in the
end I don't see that in here but maybe
there has to be something in the end
coming out of this the story or or maybe
this this is in some respect they'll
cite a different side project
[Music]
you